around 10 years ago I recorded a video
that is titled some advice about
becoming a philosophy professor and it
was responding to a student's query
about well you know I want to become a
philosophy Professor what's involved in
that and it's drawn a little over 50 000
views in those 10 years a lot of
comments a lot of discussion and I you
know it's come up every once in a while
as people make new comments and I'm like
oh I probably should update this video
and that's what I'm doing here but I'm
actually going to do a set because I
ranged across a number of topics and
there's a lot of things that people have
asked about so I am going to hear just
reapproach this question of what does it
take to become a philosophy Professor
what would I be getting myself in for
one of my prospects and I'm going to
talk about some of the other topics like
should I major in philosophy which you
know is a separate question from should
I become a philosophy Professor
obviously if you want to become a
philosophy Professor majoring in
philosophy or some other related field
is probably going to be very important
but it's not quite the same thing so I'm
going to do some other videos on other
related connected topics that were
brought up in that original one so let's
start with this one I do want to make a
few provisos right off the bat I
understand the American setting much
better than I understand how it would be
you know in even Canada let alone Europe
or other places so what I'm saying here
might apply as well to you know Great
Britain or Canada but there's no
guarantee I'm going to be talking
primarily about what goes into becoming
a professor here in in the United States
everything that I have to say here is
like Aristotle says about ethics for the
most part there will be exceptions uh
you know every single thing that's
complicated in human life does have
those I'm not claiming to know
everything about this and this brings me
to the third proposal this is going to
be based on my own experience and what
I've heard from my friends and
colleagues and even people who I don't
particularly know or care for but who
have something interesting to say about
it but the picture is going to be
partial so once again there'll be
exceptions there'll be blind spots but I
can tell you my own Reflections and what
it is that other people have to say
about the matter
the second thing that I want to say
before we jump into the nitty-gritty of
this is that I think that and this is
you know going from some of the comments
that I've had over the years it's really
really important to be realistic about
this sort of thing not unduly optimistic
Pie in the Sky I'll be the exception to
the difficulties not unduly pessimistic
oh it's all terrible it's all crap
somewhere in the middle you know we want
to look at the available information
that we have we want to think about this
in
non-hyperbolic ways and we should be
realistic about ourselves as well and
our prospects for finding the kind of
work that you know would be the ideal of
being a philosophy professor and I would
say one needs to be philosophical about
this Prospect of teaching philosophy
full-time in a professorial setting as
well as the other alternatives to that
the things that are along the same lines
but not paid quite so well or protected
or any of those sorts of matters there's
a lot of people I've also noticed who
have some fairly well worked out rather
rigid projections and plans for
themselves they're saying you know I'm
going to do this what will that
automatically lead to I should make this
decision rather this than this one and I
I do want to say there's no guarantees
when it comes to this sort of matter you
know we don't know what things are going
to be like 10 years down the line if
current trends continue it's probably
not going to be very good but you know
again we we don't really know we're not
fortune tellers so
we do want to realize how much of this
is up to chance and luck and coincidence
and how much of it is up to a rather
unfairly skewed system and how vastly
different things can play out from year
to year and from job search to job
search and candidate to candidate so all
of that said let's jump in now what's
actually required to become a philosophy
Professor well you do have to get hired
for the job but that comes at the end of
a lot of other stuff first you probably
are going to get yourself a ba in
philosophy you might you know double
major you might be in a PPE philosophy
politics economics program there might
be other ways in which you go but
generally you got to do something as an
undergraduate student that involves
studying philosophy and there's lots and
lots of places lots and lots of programs
where you can do that some of them are
very prestigious but may not actually be
all that good or they could be quite
good but not the right fit for you right
there's all sorts of factors involved
and then after you get your bachelor's
then you go on and you either go
straight into a PhD program which you
know personally I typically advise
against because I I kind of think you're
missing out on some stuff by doing that
or you know more traditionally you get
your master's degree two more years of
investment there and then you go on to
do your your doctoral work to earn your
PhD and at the Master's level you will
most likely be expected to write a
master's thesis you might have to take
some comprehensive exams although those
are often going away these days
and then at the PHD you would you know
continue doing some coursework and
eventually uh propose and then write and
then defend a book a dissertation of
your own which is the product of of
research and you know that generally
takes people three to five years
sometimes it takes them longer there
isn't a
simple recipe for it some people take a
little bit longer with their master's
degrees as well but you can expect so
you know four years of bachelor's two
years of Masters and then probably say
an average of four years at the PHD so
you're talking about a 10-year
investment to
be possible as a candidate for the jobs
that are out there to get hired to to be
a philosophy Professor to teach
philosophy and do all the other things
that a professor does as well in
addition to getting your degree you
probably would be expected also to have
some Publications in peer-reviewed
journals you know book chapters
sometimes count though a little bit less
you're probably not going to have a
whole book out there necessarily
although you know a lot of people do
turn their dissertations into their
first book
uh teaching experience is also quite
important you want to start teaching or
at least at the very least being a
teacher's assistant for some other
Professor who's teaching classes while
you are a graduate student uh you
probably want to do some various service
work as well because down the line
that's part of what they're going to
expect you to do as a professor and you
know very important is actually
networking with other people you do this
by going to conferences by presenting
papers commenting on papers by reaching
out to people participating in all sorts
of you know face-to-face and online
venues and organizations and projects
and stuff like that now I do want to say
that you've got to be very careful about
taking advice from people who've been
successful in this and think that their
recipe for Success will automatically
work for you this is a very big problem
for my generation of students because
the previous generation of professors
really had very little clue about what
the job market had turned into by the
time that I was like going out in 2002
until the job market and you know so
were my my peers
there's lots of different stories
there's lots of different circumstances
and you know what worked in different
times may not actually work for you
let's talk now about the prospects for
finding a tenure track
teaching position being a professor of
philosophy
what are the odds they're not great you
know when I first entered graduate
school in 1995 they gave us a document
that said we just want you to know only
two out of three of the phds in the past
you know in recent years ever found
full-time work now that doesn't mean
tenured that means including part-time
you know post-doc all of that sort of
stuff only two out of three are going to
to be successful with that so it's
gotten much worse in in recent years so
just as an example you know Daily News
has articles on this every year so in
the most recent Daily News article they
talk about the NSF survey of earned
doctorates and in 2021 there were 399
new phds in philosophy so that's a lot
of people right how many jobs were there
for them in the next year that we can
look at I mean we're we're going to talk
about 20 22 to 2023 because that's even
better than 2021 to 2022. so there are
372 total jobs total jobs advertised in
jobs uh in in Phil jobs right now there
may have been a couple outliers that
weren't advertised there that were
advertised in other places but
that's there's less jobs than there are
new phds on the market and you got to
remember
all the other phds who came out in
recent years they're also mostly still
looking for work
and then there's people who actually
have positions you know it might be a
tenure track position or it might be a
you know
adjuncting or uh full-time but only
limited contract or a post-doctoral
thing they're all looking for jobs too
plus you got older Scholars who maybe
want to try to use getting a job offer
as a way of getting a raise at their
institution often one of the only ways
you can get a raise right or they just
want to trade up there's also people who
get out and they kind of like try to
move up the rank so there's a lot of
people out there chasing those 372 total
jobs
not all of those jobs are 10-year track
meaning where you can get tenure
of those uh 372 total jobs 94 of them
were simply post-doc positions
post-doctoral where you're at a place
for you know maybe a year maybe three
years
um you know you settle in you do some
work there maybe you do some teaching
maybe you don't another 121 of them were
what we call fixed term positions which
might be again one year two year three
year they could be renewable but they're
not tenure track I worked a job sort of
like that when I first got out of
graduate school myself when I was
working for Ball State in their prison
education program I was not a I was not
eligible for tenure and I was not
eligible for promotion because I was
working for extended education as a
matter of fact my chair said oh I'm
really so sorry about this because given
the work that you're doing in
publication you would be an associate
professor this is like three years in
but that's just not possible so a lot of
these jobs are not tenure track jobs
now I I had some interesting things that
people said as comments that I wanted to
bring up
um the the most recent was by the 11th
doctor six days ago he said I know this
video was made a long time ago but I'm
considering majoring in philosophy as I
have exceedingly good reading and
writing skills I'm just not sure if 12
more years of school is worth the chance
of teaching philosophy now 10 years
probably the average right but you can
understand that sentiment there was
another person about a year ago who
thought I was being far too pessimistic
who said
Sumi cray whenever I see at several
universities there are so many lecturers
professors and they're specialized at
this and that I just think that they're
also human beings like me if they can do
it why can't I and we'll get to that in
a bit there isn't anything saying that
you can't get a job it's just kind of
kind of difficult
um Robert uh six years ago said as
someone who's been dreaming throughout
college to be a philosophy Professor I'm
starting to see the reality of the field
and honestly it doesn't seem appealing
grinding for years to get a degree with
not even a 50 percent conversion job
rate and not even being especially well
paid if it does work out makes the field
much less attractive that's
understandable than two years ago
Stephanie Spivak said I abandoned being
a philosophy Professor despite support
from all my professors because the job
market scares the out of me I hope
again that I don't have to settle so a
lot of interesting points of view right
so let's talk about the job market we we
use this term Market as if there's
actually some rational you know vast uh
buying and selling going on but it's not
quite like that it's actually a lot of
people say it's much more like a lottery
but it's a crooked Lottery it's not a
fair Lottery and there's a lot of things
to it that many many factors that you
just can't control and oftentimes can't
even really know much of the job you
know Lottery is is luck in various ways
there was a great uh discussion about
that on Twitter a while back that I
actually did a video about which I'll
link to below that you can check out uh
it's it's arbitrary there's a lot of
different factors that go into it
pedigree plays a role meaning where did
you go to school your prestige in
various sorts where you're currently
teaching the connections that you have
have and it's not a meritocracy in any
respect right and there's all sorts of
other things you might say kind of
facetiously it certainly doesn't hurt to
be independently wealthy if you want to
stay on the market or come from a
wealthy family or also to be not a first
generation academic to have a family who
themselves are professors as a matter of
fact you know when we look at the stats
on this sort of thing as people have
been doing lately what we do find is
that there are incredible advantages to
quite a few people that the rest of us
don't necessarily enjoy or are even
aware of and
I'm going to read some things about
what happens in the whole job
interviewing process this comes from
Paul Schofield he wrote a very
interesting Twitter thread a while back
where he said academic job Seekers often
think because they didn't get a job one
year or didn't get a particular job
there's something they should change in
their application that's often a mistake
here's some reasons maybe you didn't get
the job that are beyond your control uh
so here's the first one the ad is
written with a specific candidate in
mind who the department intends to hire
that candidate is not you very often the
fix is in from the very beginning this
happens all the time and you never know
it until you get tipped off in some way
number two the ad lists and area of
specialization the department has
decided it's not going to hire in either
because listing it was a ploy to get the
line approved or the department changed
their mind once they looked at the
applicant pool this is your area of
specialization you never had a chance
number three you get eliminated in the
first round for a job you're qualified
for because the initial screening is
given to one or two people who are
overworked and trying to be aggressive
when whittling down the pool you
disappear and are forgotten after two
minutes
so many
job pools consist of anywhere from 200
to a thousand candidates one of the main
jobs of the selection or hiring
committees is to get rid of as many
applications as they can right at the
start
number four the department thinks you're
too much like or not enough like the
other members of the department both of
these can be reasons for throwing off a
candidate and you never know which it is
when you send an application off
number five there's another candidate in
the market exactly like you and
departments are picking between you and
that person perhaps arbitrarily perhaps
on the basis of some leg up that person
has you're otherwise perfect but this
person's existence ruins your year or
career number six everyone loves you
except one member of the committee and
as unfair as maybe that person is being
it's easier to find a candidate that
Everyone likes than it is to fight with
one's colleague nothing you could have
done would have changed this person's
mind number seven
someone on the committee speculates on
the basis of little or no evidence that
you won't stay if you're hired your
attempts to Signal otherwise are taken
as defensiveness about this making your
professed desire to stay all the more
reason to treat you as a Flight Risk
number eight the committee doesn't think
your work needs to improve they hate
what you're doing so attempts to make it
better to clarify it just make them
angrier and more likely to throw out
your application it's not the quality of
the work they hate it's the work
number nine the committee illegally
discriminates against you that sort of
stuff does happen I've seen hiring
committees where that that happens
number 10 you've published too much or
too little both are reasons for
rejecting a candidate by publishing more
and making yourself more attractive to
some you make yourself less desirable to
others 11. a Committee Member totally
misreads your application and eliminates
you no one protests because they all
want to go to lunch you receive the
rejection and it's you assume it's
because Professor X disagreed with the
footnote on page 27 of your writing
sample when really it has nothing to do
with that finally number 12 a member on
the committee has a preferred candidate
and it's not you you are serious
competition though so the Committee
Member tries to take you out early
others see what's going on but don't
want to fight with his colleague and
again want to go out to lunch now these
are just 12 possible ways in which
things can and often do go wrong in the
hiring selection so just be aware that
there's a lot of Caprice a lot of chance
a lot of you know
Randomness even or you know things going
wrong that are quite possible even if
you are a great candidate even if you've
done everything that you're supposed to
do
and so here's another interesting topic
this actually comes from a piece called
the cruelty of the adjunct system by
Alexander bradner
um you know it's it's depressing to be
on the market year after year and there
could be all sorts of emotions involved
as well now bradner is talking about
what it's like to be non-tenure track
faculty and her piece says you know that
Beyond regret sorrow anxiety and fear
non-tenure track faculty live with toxic
feelings of failure now notice she's not
just talking about adjunct she's
actually talking about other people who
just don't have tenure track positions
but are being hired year to year what
else do they feel anger at all sorts of
things their their profession their
colleagues guilt gratitude love pride
and then one of the lines she says is
but mostly there's overwhelming sadness
does this have to be the case no not
necessarily
but it is a challenge an emotional
challenge that you do want to be quite
aware of
the American philosophical Association
has a very long and detailed guide for
philosophy job Seekers and they talk
about applying for the five basic kinds
of academic positions positions at elite
private and Flagship state universities
positions at Regional comprehensives
what they call second-tier public
institutions positions at liberal arts
colleges positions at two-year colleges
and online positions what they're
leaving out there of course is adjunct
work right what does it mean to be an
adjunct
so to be an adjunct is to be somebody
who is hired term to term you don't have
the expectation in any sort of contract
of continuing employment you are hired
per class and you know in some cases
adjuncts may be paid quite well per
class you know
at some institutions that treat their
adjuncts pretty decently I've seen
adjuncts paid as much as six thousand or
seven thousand dollars per class
but that's the high end you can also
find cases where they're paid as low as
sixteen hundred dollars per class to
teach an entire semester and then
everything in between you know it varies
from region to region and institution to
institution there is no one single rate
out there there is uh an interesting you
know a lot of self-reported data because
adjuncts have been filling out these
spreadsheets where you can find out what
they're actually earning and
the odds are
you're more likely to adjunct throughout
your career than you are to get a tenure
track job as a professor who has job
security and decent pay and all the
other things that go along with it and
you know to adjunct year after year
after year really tends to burn people
out if it's your sole source of income
it really sucks because you have to
Cobble together effectively a career for
yourself going from school to school to
school none of which really care about
you as a person even your colleagues May
steal classes from you I've had that
happen to me as an adjunct where I
developed a class and then my colleague
was like I think I'll take that over and
yeah they that's pretty common right or
you may get hired one semester that not
get hired back and not even know why
right so there's a lot that you have to
think about with that
even if you're not an adjunct but you're
you have a full-time position but it's
not tenure track so you can't be
guaranteed of being there it can still
be quite difficult Jeremy Davis has a
great piece called my five years on the
philosophy job market where it does have
a happy ending he gets a tenure track
job eventually right but he says this
moving around for years living in
relative Financial precarity constantly
having to do confusing and time
consuming administrative paperwork in
new places finding new doctors paying
first last month rent before receiving
the return deposit from your previous
apartment wondering if you'll ever be
able to find longer term stability in a
place losing and making new friends
generally just uprooting your entire
life and that of your spouse partner
family these are unfortunately pretty
standard occupational hazards in the
field and this does take a toll on
people I had a colleague when I was at
Fayetteville State who had had seven
jobs in nine years moving from place to
place to place all the way across the
United States
every almost every year but sometimes
having a reprieve not having to move
until the next year and it just burned
her out you know by the time that she
got her tenure track job we got hired at
the same time at Fayetteville State
University as new uh assistant
professors on the tenure track
she just you know was worn out from all
of that that stress
so again I'm not trying to dissuade
anybody if you really really want to try
to be a professor it is
possible but it's difficult uh quite
often to to get into those positions
most likely you're going to get uh
adjunct or part-time you know or
full-time but without job security kind
of work but you could think about uh
what if you do happen to get it what if
you land a 10-year track job what what
is the life of a philosophy Professor
like we imagine it as you know being
surrounded by books and having these
colleagues that we we get to talk to in
wonderful conversations and students who
are paying attention all the time and
challenging us and you know moving from
virtue to Virtue as they say writing our
books writing our articles doing all the
things that are so important to the life
of the mind and yeah you get to do that
some of the time I mean I I I've had a
tenure track job you also do lots and
lots of other stuff lots of committee
meetings you may be advising students uh
you have to you know do not just writing
your own stuff but also be willing to
review other people's things and you can
expect that
probably
not a not a great number of people are
going to be looking at reading getting
excited about your work probably the
students that you're teaching will be an
interesting mix now I certainly myself
I've had a great time with my students
from from the beginning all the way up
to this year I've been teaching for 22
or 23 years at this point quite a while
and you know I I like teaching people
who are not philosophy Majors because I
think that's a great way to have
connection between philosophy and the
rest of the world
but that can be tough for a lot of
people who are teaching and would really
love for students to be a bit more
engaged impressed even interested in the
vast world of philosophy and you just
can't take that for granted and even in
Elite institutions because quite a few
of those Elite institutions some of the
students are there just as legacies or
you know their parents made donations or
they're there you know on on this
scholarship and that scholarship and
they don't care about your philosophy
class which is just something to get
through if you happen to be lucky enough
to teach graduate students graduate
students are pretty easy to teach
because they're self-motivated right
um it's tougher to teach the students
who aren't quite sure why they're taking
a philosophy class and you know as a
professor you have teaching which is a
very important part of the job you have
you know doing your research search and
then you have service you have to do all
sorts of other things as well
we can also say that on the whole
salaries for professors are you know new
hires are kind of declining
um they're not getting paid quite what
they were back in the past it's very
interesting at some of the places that I
teach where you can see the vast
disparity between those who were hired
20 years ago and those who are being
hired right now it's not even close to
comparable but this depends from
institution to institution right some
institutions have the the money the
budgets to pay very well and do so some
of them do have the money to do that and
then don't you know they may have a
significant endowment but they treat
their new hires and not just professors
but staff quite poorly
we can also talk about two big issues uh
that are essentially political issues
academic freedom and tenure now you know
in most places academic freedom is
pretty well respected as a general
principle and there's fewer and fewer
tenure track jobs more and more adjunct
work and um you know renewable contracts
than actual tenured stuff but there are
still quite a few places where that
exists but it's often being threatened
in the case of tenure sometimes it's
political and sometimes it's just that
the administrators would like to get rid
of it so that they can turn the
workforce into a much more dependent
Workforce that they can hire and fire at
will in the case of academic freedom
we're seeing that there are states where
conservatives are particular necessarily
targeting the State University Systems
telling professors what they can and
can't teach right so this is a
significant issue and it's probably
going to continue on so I want to finish
this up by saying you know I've thrown a
lot of information at you and it may
sound pretty Doom and Gloom but again I
think it's very important to be
realistic if you want to try to be a
philosophy Professor there's nothing
that will stop you from you know say
going and majoring in philosophy and
then per you know perhaps going on to
graduate school but there's no guarantee
that you're going to get that job at the
end either there wasn't a guarantee even
for my generation coming out over 20
years ago there's even less guarantee in
the present were you to begin today and
10 years down the line you know with
your PhD and hand start applying for
jobs it is possible anything is possible
but
it is tricky and so you know if you
really want to do this you should think
about it there's other possibilities
there's many things you can do with
philosophy I'll talk about those in
other videos you don't necessarily have
to go to university to study philosophy
being a professor is not the only thing
that you have to shoot for but it is it
is something that I think a lot of
people interested in philosophy have as
an ideal for themselves and so I just
wanted to you know give an update and my
thoughts and those of others that are I
would say
fairly well within the consensus of the
discipline about all of these matters
and hopefully this gives you some food
for thought it doesn't just bring you
down but you know tempers any sort of
Pie in the Sky idealism that you might
have towards something a bit more
realistic in orientation